heads up major Avengers infinity war
spoilers coming your way on top of
having the most devastating ending the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has ever seen
infinity war has a pretty bleak
beginning and middle as well full of
goodbyes to favorite characters right
from the opening scene while audiences
wait to see who returns to finish the
fight in Avengers 4 one performer and
the long-running series have just let
people know he's probably not coming
back
ETS Alba the English actor who played
the Asgardian Guardian Heimdall that did
a fond farewell to his character on
Twitter in the post he wrote hashtag
spoiler alert gonna miss my guy Heimdall
the post seemingly confirmed that the
keeper of the Bifrost who was among the
very first characters to meet their
demise drawing palaces ourselves was one
of the Marvel heroes we could consider
gone for good
but regardless of why Alba says now the
record seems to show that he's had
anything but a loving public
relationship with Marvel Studios as far
back as Thor the dark world elbow was
making delightfully and friendly
comments to the media about how Marvel
movies are quote a torture and how the
indignity of working on them quote
ripped his heart out
Sharada of course with the central
MacGuffin of infinity war being a magic
glove that can turn back time there's no
telling whether or not Alba is truly
going to be free from the franchise
after all Avengers 4 wrapped filming in
January before infinity war was even
released over May of heimdal in the way
of view but that doesn't mean his
character doesn't have a scene or two in
the fourth movie if the actors Instagram
is anything to go by over spent infinity
war weekend racing single-seater formula
II cars in Paris France doesn't seem
like he's too bummed about his newfound
freedom but if he does end up making a
surprise return well he wouldn't be the
first Asgardian warrior to come back to
life Avengers infinity war continues to
set box-office records and the next
movie in the MCU series ant-man and the
wasp it sets a swamp theatres in early
July
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
you
[Music]